alors que les ministres des neuf de
l'agriculture discute à bruxelles de
problème redoutable celui du vin en
particulier celui du lait de la viande
on trouve aux abords de limoges des
petits agriculteurs tout petits
agriculteurs qui n'ont pas de problème
cela ne descendent pas dans la rue ne
manifeste pas ne met pas d'obstacle
circulation routière ou ferroviaire
ce sont des gens heureux et des gens qui
n'ont pas de charges sociales vous allez
les découvrir et je n'ai qu'un seul prix
qui mesurent dans les 30 m de long comme
vous pouvez le constater je compte
faire le pont
nous n'autorisons pas peu près le même
c'est à pied que vous avez soigneusement
sélectionnés non aux pieds à peu près
dix ans lorsque le prix le jardin il
existait déjà il avait un homme donc
neuf ans que je leur lève sur les dix
ans mais je bien entretenu je les
tailles et tous les ans et je les veux
le suivre par lignes parallèles 2 il
fait 30 mètres de l'homme
vous faites un bon petit vin pas mauvais
mais il faut ajouter un peu de sucre
sinon vous faites appel à la main
d'oeuvre étrangère pour vous aider oui
je prends toujours un étranger avec moi
vous faites de la polyculture ici vous
et la vigne bien sûr leur côté un peu de
tout le port les oignons puis des
premiers voiliers
j'ai pas grave si ca m arrière
verrouillage pas très grand mais en fait
je les appelais le domaine de la sias de
la chasse sch ya deux ans c'est une
raison
parce que la première a mené que j'étais
du yen avec un copain
on a fait hier une douzaine à 2 litres
mais on l'avait fait pas fait dans les
règles de l'art premier avait pas sucré
et le jouerons la coulée on a bu un
litre en cassant la croûte
alors on en attrape élus locaux et si un
jour un promoteur venait prendre vos
terrains pour construire la caisse que
vous dire aïe aïe aïe alors là j'irai
ailleurs je chercherai à notre jardin
nous ferions notre pied de ligne il
atteindrait 10 ans pour récolter les
jardins ouvriers se fait longtemps
qu'ils existent limoges pour tenter de
vous payer cher de location fermage
2400 francs par an c'est pas cher aux
portes de limoges n'ont rien qu'avec mon
ben ça y est pour un petit agriculteur
comme vous c'est rentable une
exploitation de ce genre oh oui pour
retraités c'est rentable
on va traiter oui alors les agriculteurs
se plaignent actuellement vous estimez
quand même qu'on peut faire son beurre
avec un bon jardin ou au jardin oui
quand la saison est bonne